congratulations you've just blown up the
bachelorette oh damn
he said it a new promo for the upcoming
season of the bachelorette aired monday
night
and the whole thing seems to suggest
that this might actually be
the most dramatic season ever in the
sneak peek
bachelorette claire crawley can be seen
kissing a few guys
dropping an l-bomb still falling in love
with you unapologetically sending one
guy
home i'm not done yet you are done get
out of here and of course what with a
bachelorette be without
a few tears you just don't know when
it's gonna happen
then of course there's the show's host
chris harrison delivering one
seriously dramatic ominous af line
congratulations you've just blown up the
bachelorette yeah so the promo doesn't
go into detail about what exactly claire
did to blow up the bachelorette
but e.t learned last month that claire
fell for a contestant roughly two weeks
into filming
wrapping up her reign as the
bachelorette for me i'm like
with claire done tasha adams was brought
on as the show's new lead
we got a brand new teaser for claire
crawley season
as part of yes as part of tonight's
episode it ends with chris harrison
saying claire
you blew up the bachelorette
yes now he finally has he always holds
things against me i feel like claire can
take that now
on monday et caught up with former
bachelorette caitlyn bristow
who gave us her two cents what do you
think do you think
this season is going to be the most
dramatic ever
i mean chris harrison is known for being
dramatic and that seems pretty dramatic
so we'll have to tune and find out how
dramatic it is well
from the sound of it it's pretty
freaking dramatic i mean
we shall see right abc and warner
brothers have yet to confirm the switch
from claire to tasia
but they teased an explosive turn of
events in a recent press release
i'm sorry say that again last week
taisha returned to social media
after a month-long hiatus a sign that
filming on season 16
has wrapped so what'd she post the 30
year old shared
this selfie to her insta story writing
hi it's been a minute
and shared this pic celebrating the big
3-0
her caption i am 30 i am definitely
flirty and i'm
thriving